changing the visual properties of an
element only changes how the element is
displayed not what kind of element it is
you should be sure to choose the right
type of element for certain parts of a
page depending on what the purpose of
that element is for example in this page
the title at the top of the page is
really text giving the user an
understanding of what is on the page so
you should be using a tag that provides
such information think of it in terms of
a Microsoft Word Google Doc or
OpenOffice document when you're typing
in a document you might select different
headings in order to tell the user what
part of the document they're reading in
HTML you can do the exact same thing
except we call these tags h1 and h2 h3
etc search engines also use headings to
index the structure and content of a
webpage therefore you can change the div
tag to the more appropriate h1 tag for
our title go ahead and do so and then
refresh your browser and tell me what
happened what did happen to the text my
app did nothing visibly change or did
the text change in size or did the box
around the text change be sure to select
any and all that apply